says essentially if you create an
intelligence that's Superior to human
intelligence it will wipe us out I don't
know if you've read Lucy Shin's uh book
The Dark Forest which is the sequel to
The Three body problem but in that he
argues that if there's any Superior
intelligence in the universe
if it discovers us it will immediately
eradicate us just in case we might
eradicate it and that dark Forest theory
is kind of what yukovsky is saying
that's why the headline was you know the
aliens are here and we created them if
you think of artificial intelligence as
non-human intelligence which would be a
much better thing to call it I think
artificial intelligence sounds a little
bit harmless but if you called it
non-human or inhuman intelligence then
you'd recognize that you're creating
aliens within and I think the yukovsky
argument is if you create an
intelligence Superior to ours we should
expect to be eradicated